what was cooler being a Vulcan
councilmember in Star Trek or Star Fleet
Admiral and into darkest well you know
it's a it's it's a draw and I'll tell
you why the Vulcan council membership
was not only my first foray into screen
Trek but I got a bubbled up card which
is framed in lucite in my office having
said that when Conn attacks the council
chamber I'm to incarnate acts the the
meeting and into darkness Bruce
Greenwood and I are shot a lot and
lurched forward and they were they
offered a stunt performer for me but I
said no and they gave me kneepads and I
got a stunt bump
so technically on for a day I was a
stunt person so you can see that they're
sort of neck-and-neck when it comes to
joy that's that's fantastic
by the way I'm sure you would have paid
to be a stunt performer in a Star Trek I
would have paid to do anything in a Star
Trek anything so the fact that I get to
do so much in Star Trek things is an
extraordinarily impossible Star Trek The
Next Generation probably my all-time
favorite show
I love it I definitely want to know um
how much you paid to work on Picard I so
I have Polaroid's of Alex Kurtzman and
and I sold them back to you know my so I
am like you in that although older so my
favorite show is TOS
as my first Star Trek convention was
1976 I was 14 years old and my mother
somehow let me Billie why directly
Gretzky Nick Gunny
and tell Ben I got a hotel room it's
that real crazy a lot of
that was when pot had seeds and stepped
UOP rolled it on a record get the seeds
in Stata and and there was this thing
that we had I had been watching it needs
to be on WPIX channel eleven seven
o'clock every night first-run
syndication I'm I don't mind remembers
the show itself in first-run I probably
saw one episode with my father so for me
came in first-run syndication and even
then the episodes were being somewhat
reduced for commercials and you know
what passed for televisions for color
televisions at that point you know had
nothing to do with the color that we see
today so what he went to a Star Trek
convention you could suddenly see these
the real blues and the Mia and like the
phaser cannon that's kind of in the rock
wall scenes for next week I mean it was
as if God had landed and delivered unto
you the opportunity to be a missed all
that was extraordinary and in those days
the community was smaller so I remember
Isaac Asimov Gerald was there for when
Allison was that you know I need serve
and everybody would speak I still have
the borough shorts hand tight some
herminia grafted you know I think God
left and so you know you talked about
fringe some years later after I had
talked to my friend JJ I introduced him
to his wife and allows me endless
opportunities to get favors back so
after I had talked him into putting me
in a couple of Star Trek and somewhere
in there I had said look I would like to
try to direct something I had just
directed an episode of Kings I would
like to try to direct an episode of
Fringe it just started your show Fringe
seems fun to me said I and he said well
you have to write it and I said I don't
want to break it I just want directed
he's a toffee up to rights
so I tried to write a fringe episode
which I did Jeff Pinkner
sent me back to outline a web in time
because it turns out wedding a TV
episode his heart and I didn't know how
and so then I went I wrote and directed
this episode the sort of beginning of
middle of first season called bad dreams
I think and I never left
I was drunk uncle on that show for
years my you know and I couldn't have
been were delighted and so somewhere a
couple of years ago alex kurtzman right
who was one of the co-creators of Fringe
finds himself he's off shooting a movie
there's some sort of turmoil on Star
Trek and he's like could you go just
sort of help hold it together and get
launched it and it's the same thing I've
never left I mean a villa they let me in
and now they just can't get rid of I I
live for it it's my favorite thing it's
so counterproductive because I should be
doing all sorts of other things in all I
want to do is Star Trek home
I understand completely if I was given
keys to the Ferrari I would also say I'm
not giving them back
you know I've got it so I'm very curious
I know Picard got a season two and you
guys were were you close to shooting
were you shooting we were not shooting
we were to start shooting in
which be nine yeah I guarantee you we
will not unless the world opens tomorrow
we had broke in the season we are about
halfway through the writing of it and
you know we will start as soon as we can
once the world over you know we will you
know the prep will have to resume and
and then we'll start so I mean we know
it is and it's cool and we're excited by
it and you know I feel like we've
learned a lot from season one it's easy
and of the things that I have in my life
it is the one that is most imminent when
the world real sorry it's the one that
feels like that's the thing that's gonna
at least in my line come back fast he
says though I I had heard and maybe you
can correct this but I had heard the
card was always envisioned as a
preseason show um any truth I mean I
think that we have discussed it as both
a three season show a five season show a
let's just keep going forever show I
think that probably that three season
thing my guess is and I do not know this
to the effect that there probably to
seasonal option pickups in the deal
you're gonna be so easy
but we certainly um
Star Trek Picard in my view will go as
long as Patrick Stewart wants to do yeah
that's the thing I was going to say is
that um you know he is not a young man
anymore I love him to death
love um but you know how long does he
want to play the role yeah I look and
that's really the question right I mean
you know as I'm sure you know he was not
interested in coming back
and we you know did a lot of autumn back
and a lot of really good collaborative
story breaking and talking and you know
and I think he's particularly delighted
in in a good way now about having come
back you know when we will rely on that
good well good ripple until he feels
he's done he mentioned you're halfway
through breaking season two there is an
advantageous thing to I mean it's the
only good thing that happens with this
endemic for a card is you are getting
more time with the scripts and also it's
possible that you can finish the whole
season so when you deuce in the in the
writers room so when you do go set out
to film you can lock film what you need
in certain locations for all the
episodes or is that not possible though
yes to the first part no to the second
so to the first part it is fundamentally
a gift to be able to do all of them if
you can write because unlike previous
iterations of television this serialized
10 hour narrative has set ups and
payoffs that you know require a kind of
thoughtful view of the object once it's
completed it's very funny in the first
season of the court there were all these
reviews of the first the beginning oh
it's so dark it's so dark it's so dark
and I kept saying they're reviewing the
first act of a movie like the first act
of a movie is always dark if you stopped
it's a Wonderful Life at the bridge it's
a really dark movie like because
fundamentally and they want for
narrative it's it's a redemption story
it's a healing story it has to be bad at
the beginning so it gets good at the end
like otherwise there's nothing to fix so
you know we are in this weird world now
where we created one narrative object
but we do lit out bit by bit which is
fascinating and can be kind of fun but
what you really want is to be able to
refine yourselves once you've written
your papers so if they have you know
let's learn to write 10 hours first that
would be a maze and maybe we will
in terms of shooting we do block shoot
reflection in episodes of two but the
way it works with the Directors Guild is
you can't you know I mean like unless we
had one director doing the whole thing
then you'd actually have I can't shoot
something for Jonathan Frakes eyes you
know you wrap season 1 come out have you
all of a sudden gotten a lot more phone
calls from people saying they would
really love to helm an episode in season
2 well that I haven't I mean that would
be secret hideout more you know um and
they but you know the truth is we have a
you know it's a little II there are only
five directors Percy's it right because
it's two episode blocks so you know
anybody who pretty much wants to come
back home season one is coming back and
again that might mean a slot open my
last thing for you about Picard but I
could keep on going you obviously
Jonathan breaks you had some I you know
key characters from the first season or
any of those characters and you tease
any of your word you know of who might
be visiting in season two
no no I get it listen I I you know I
have to understand yeah and by the way I
have so many questions so someone on
Twitter and I want to include a Twitter
question said what kind of ship was de
la Sierra it was unlike any other ship
we'd seen on trip a de la serena why
English II know what is it it's a
modified cargo ship it's non Federation
and and that's all we made it up wait
things are made up in Star Trek when I
say may not we got that telescope that
what's in the future and we found it of
course since I'm running out of time I'm
gonna go through a bunch of questions a
lot of us have been wondering about
lower decks what's the status I have
nothing to do with lower exp so
desperate to watch like literally
couldn't seem funnier today have you
seen any of it no I there was a test
real going around the office and I
didn't see it it that sucks but no but
no but I've seen the steel frames and I
you know the pitches for it or [ __ ] like
literally the pitch for it is the
funniest thing ever second contact I
mean it's the greatest thing ever
I we're all ready to watch yeah we just
want to see it actually in jeans are
there any updates on this pipe series
you
are you just nodding your head because
you can't say or you won't say all those
things can't say ain't saying don't know
we should know could know what about the
section 31 I don't know I honestly I
know I know that I know that I know that
there were or our scripts being
developed for section 31 I mean I I I
know I
you're not involved but I love the way
you end in Star Trek discovery season 2
it opens up this huge new possibility
for season 3
what can you tease people about third
season I can't
another I know no I I'm not on discovery
now I just know things so just regard
today look for you
obviously you watch Discovery I'm just
curious about the ending of season 2 and
as I know I look we all helped build
that idea even all the way back to
season one Aaron Harvard said Gretchen
Berg the original show runners and sees
the show airs of season one like that
idea dates all the way back to that I
think it's a spectacular idea which is
to you know to go post the push the
timeline we know I think Alex Kurtzman
so alex has really been deeply involved
in the building out of what season 3
looks like and you know and what that
post federation future is and I have not
I've seen some of it I mean you know
because we all work together in the same
what we did place with lots of pictures
of Star Trek on the wall in editing
Bay's and things and it seems awesome I
mean I think it is it's a final it's not
a final frontier but it's it's a new one